right the giga year is
essentially the unit that astronomers
use to denote time when you're measuring
things in astronomy it's useful when the
numbers don't come out too big or too
small like it's just like you know when
you somebody asks how old you are you
tend to give your age in years rather
than in seconds just because you end up
with a number that's sort of 10 or 20 or
30 rather than something that's millions
or billions
it's basically a billion years sort of
the smallest time scale where you can
see cosmological things happening in the
universe especially on the scale of
galaxies so we just define units that
are the sort of the natural units to
measure things in and when you're
measuring things to do with the age of
the universe the giga year the billion
years is the most natural unit to use
because the universe itself is about 14
billion years old well uh one one thing
is that a simple uh garden snail
in a gig year that is in one billion
years would crawl around the earth's
circumference
about 10 million times so you can
imagine it would take quite a long time
for garden smell to to even move a short
distance but in a giga year it could go
around the uh the earth uh 10 million
times there's already a number which is
already too hard to understand so when
you call it a giga year you kind of hide
how big it is because it's you know 13.7
gigabytes and that sounds like quite a
sensible number it's only 13.7 but
actually you know you've hidden all the
all the stuff you don't really have a
grasp for in the unit 13.7 billion years
and how long's a billion years it's not
something that i have any real physical
feel for
it
to to try to understand what a gig ear
is is very difficult it's like anything
with with astronomical units with
distances with times
uh
human beings really can't envision what
exactly
you know a gigger is if i'm told that
the earth is four billion years old
or four giga years old then i
immediately put that in the context of
knowing that the universe is 13.7 giga
years old and so you know the earth's
about as third as old as the universe so
in those kind of relative terms you can
kind of understand it but then when you
sort of step back and think well how big
is a billion years how big is a good
year
that's when you really kind of start
struggling to actually have a physical
grasp for what's going on but i really
understand what it means it's not
something you can do it's something that
in fact most astronomers just tend not
to even think about or worry about um
after being in the field for actually
not very long
uh you can't really stop and try to
think about what is you know what is a
giggy or what is what is 100 million
light years you know what are these
distances mean what do these time scales
mean because you really can't imagine
what they are
from our daily experiences even our
lifetimes so for example one of the
things that's a very active area of
astronomy now one of the things we study
here in nottingham is the formation of
galaxies something that would happen in
a gig year would be for example a galaxy
merger you have two galaxies smashed
together uh and they form a new galaxy
and that will happen in about a gig year
we're slowly pushing back towards the
beginning to understand how galaxies
first started to form but they're still
forming today and in fact you know a
galaxy like our own the milky way it's
still changing it's still evolving in
structure so in that sense you know the
formation of a galaxy is something that
takes something comparable to the
lifetime of the universe to happen so
it's something that occurs over tens of
billions of years tens of giga years you
have in some cases some stars some
middle mass stars will die
in about a gig year
but things like our sun will live for
about 10 gig years and the earth is
about five giga years currently
and
will presumably not live past the sun's
age so it has another five giga years
left so we're sort of in the middle
between this this 10 gigs and the
universe itself is about 13.67 gig years
old
most other things happen rather on while
the shorter time scales so the formation
of a star for example will take hundreds
of thousands to maybe a million years to
happen so a thousandth of a gear so it's
a tiny fraction of a giga well another
common unit in astronomy is the mega
year which is m y r
and that's that's million years so it's
10 to the sixth years
and that's the a very quick time scale
and for astronomy
astronomical processes usually take much
longer than a million years and that
gets used sort of geologically if you're
interested in the the formation of the
geology of the earth formation of rocks
and so on that happens over over those
kind of millions of years time scales um
formations of stars can take millions of
years so again that's something you'd
measure in mega years but the only one
that really gets commonly used is the
billion years